yeah this is what's scary about the
democrats winning do you know about the
great reset
we've talked we talked about this a
little bit earlier i don't think we had
an end up conversation
you know about the group tell me can you
can you google search great reset yeah i
have an article i think from the time
i've heard of this the world economic
forum is basically saying that like
covet is an opportunity to reset global
capitalism oh wonder oh fantastic that's
great
under intersectional values that's good
good i'm really glad to hear that
that's exactly i'm not so i'm i'm just
i'm just joshing around i'm very
unhappy about that it's funny because if
they didn't put it on their website and
i said this they'd be like temple's a
crazy conspiracy crackbot
i'm still saying it yep it's literally
just the it's it's the
the great reset here you go check it out
world economic forum the great reset oh
my gosh
there isn't this and yeah so there's an
urgent need for global stakeholders to
cooperate and simultaneously managing
the direct consequences of the covet 19
crisis
to improve the state of the world the
world economic forum is starting the
great
reset initiative it's kind of like
an ominous name for a cycle that's
unbelievably creepy i mean how
is it isn't there a fun irony like
people associating capitalism as it's
referred to in this context to free
markets and yet this is literally the
definition of a planned economy like you
cannot reset
a market that's not how it works they
have historically the greeks actually
reset their economy when inflation got
too crazy they were just like
and so did venezuela saying no to debt
they reduced all the debt to zero and
started over
like could you imagine issued a new
currency it was called like the bolivar
fuerte
so they're the banks venezuela oh the
bank of international settlements
releasing crypt i mean they're basically
going digital
i think i think i think this bitcoin is
going to become astronomically valuable
like
you you hear these people i'm i'm not
going to give a hard number because i'm
not i don't know but listen
i hear people saying like bitcoin is
going to hit 28k soon and they're always
giving these big numbers like bitcoins
going to this going sky high
bitcoin is an international trade medium
a digital asset that can be transferred
instantly
and it's the perfect tool for a store of
value
considering we're in digital spaces
we're doing things remote we've locked
everything down
and it can travel instantly across
borders and you can't print as much of
it as you want
so exactly there's a finite amount it's
it's the perfect medium for some kind of
international store of value
and i think with this great reset
whatever they end up doing with it
they're kind of vague but they do talk
about you know just like
intersectionality
they have a bunch of articles yeah
here's here's a question uh i have for
you tim
based on what i'm reading on the world
economic forum which i assume would just
be a solid resource for learning about
econ
yeah uh what is intersectionality and
how can it help businesses tackle
diversity and inclusion
exactly a great question and here it is
from the world economic forum website
oh cool and she's painting her eyelids
she's painting her eyelids with rainbows
the diversity and inclusion battle will
only be won when people are seen as
multi-faceted in their social identities
intersectionality
intersectionality is a way of
understanding how and why every
individual's view of the world is
different
but how ability is it allowed to be from
disability to race to age inclusivity
none should be tackled in isolation
inclusion means everyone
all the time not some people some of the
time i think it would be really great if
they talked to the american
intersectionals about you know white
people
because then they could hear this and be
like oh wait we're not supposed to treat
people that way
it's your own ideology man yeah it's
fantastic so this
this is the crazy thing is that we have
these democrats that are locking
everything down
and i wonder to what extent you have
democratic governors who like this idea
of intersectionality black lives matter
and the great reset
and i wonder how much what they're doing
may be motivated by the world economic
forum
talking about money they mentioned age
so you think this is a bunch of 90 year
old
people that plan on living until they're
at 6 000 and they're like now's the time
to get it in their minds
speaking of age though uh people talk
about income inequality as though we
just have these fixed brackets in the
united states but the reality is it's
unbelievably fluid and
one of the number one drivers of income
inequality is age like if you correct
for age
income inequality i wouldn't say
entirely evens out but it's reduced
greatly it's just people who work
more and have worked for you know in in
their industry a longer amount of time
and have more experience are just
wealthier than people this is actually
this is actually crazy i was reading
something about this it looks
i could be wrong i was just reading some
stats it seems like wealth inequality
among millennials
is insane i can see it so
like there's a small tiny bit of
millennials who are extremely wealthy
and then the most are extremely poor
like the the av
i think this is what i saw the average
net worth of a yeah this is okay the
average net worth of a millennial
is eleven thousand dollars but the
median is 75
000. wow what is the median exactly the
median is just the middle from the
highest to the lowest oh okay
for how many there are and the yeah so
the and the average is
the like all of them to get divided so
the average is really low but the median
is like seven
times higher so there are millennials
who are super wealthy
well-off i mean maybe it's a youtube
youtubers it's just youtubers think
about
the only millennials making any money
youtubers and everyone else is just
screwed why
why is it that so many millennials are
commies or socialists that's true
makes perfect sense but dude and then
the small percentage that are
conservative or just the really rich
ones is like
actually these principles make more
sense or just
having a net worth higher than eleven
thousand dollars yeah that'll do it
that'll make you not a communist is
having a net worth more than eleven
thousand dollars think about if you
inherit something from your parents the
family business yeah stake in the family
business you're already worth more
yes so i i i that's something we should
probably look up i wonder if
conservatives have a higher net worth
than
liberal millennials no doubt well i know
they're very surprised
there was a video i did on this a while
ago for the foundation for economic
education which if you'd like we started
a new youtube channel the foundation for
economic education it's called common
sense soapbox with seamus coughlin
but we did a video a while ago on income
inequality we also
we did a video on um inheritance taxes
and the way it shakes out uh inheritance
taxes actually make income inequality
worse
because poor people are more likely to
inherit their wealth
or they inherit a larger percentage of
their wealth than do the rich
wow yeah because why is that but it's a
uh well
so a lot of um actually a lot of
inherited wealth is like
inherited businesses so like farmland
and such and when you have an
inheritance tax like it really hurts
farmers the people producing our food
who are exactly like
who you don't want to hurt but who for
whatever reason marxists just have this
tendency to screw over which is one of
the reasons their economies never work
but yeah it just happens to be the case
that um poor people are more dependent
upon intergenerational wealth than the
rich are and that's because the rich
parent will make their kids wealthy
before they die i don't know i'm not
sure exactly what the explanation is i
just know it shakes out such that poor
people inherit a larger percentage of
their net worth than do the rich i think
that makes sense like the
the poor parents won't be able to give
their kids anything until they
right but think about what wealth is
right so it just
just because let me stop if a poor
person owns a house worth fifty thousand
dollars in the middle of nowhere
that means the wealth of the child is
the fifty thousand dollars
yeah exactly whereas somebody who earns
their money is going to be worth way
more than that if they become wealthy
so they're earning their income through
industry but the average person earns
their value through
having it passed down you know
generation to generation so i'm i'm
actually you know
this is why we have commies now this is
why millennials are all for bernie and
whatever even though he's
in favor of the billionaires or i guess
they and i i
look i i got to say i don't blame all of
the millennials some of them are more
responsible than others yeah but think
about what happened to this generation
i remember when i was growing up they
said go to college and i said why
and they said so you can get a good job
and i said why do i need a job to make
money how can i just make money
so i remember i read this article from
an economist who said it's a terrible
investment
imagine going to an investor and saying
for forty thousand dollars after four
years you will owe forty thousand
dollars plus interest
and they would laugh in your face what i
have to show for it piece of paper
that's ridiculous yeah yeah so i
ultimately was like i'm not gonna do it
but
millennials all go to college because
they're parents like you have to
and i've talked to a ton of my friends
all throughout the years and they keep
saying my parents are making me and i'm
like dude you're an adult
like you're not you're 19 years old i'm
like well i live at home with my parents
they'll kick me out
okay go go get a job what are you doing
well this is interesting i don't know i
mean i wouldn't say that this is
intentional but the way it shakes out
the entire student loan crisis as well
as the fact that college education is as
expensive as it is
and the entire infrastructure we have
built around higher education is a
massive handout to the corporate world
because what a college degree allows you
to do is
is determine whether or not somebody
would be a suitable worker for your
company so you don't really have to go
through as much of a trial period with
them if someone has a degree they
probably are a more promising worker
but that person spent the money i mean
this is what they are more likely to
hire people with degrees sure sure but i
know
no i no i 100 agree that that logic can
be flawed but for the most part
employers do find knowing whether or not
a person is college educated to be very
useful in their
desire to employ and so they're almost
like these litmus tests that people are
paying for on their own
to pursue these careers and then on top
of that when you're massively in debt
you
are more dependent upon your employer
you're less likely to strike or go off
on your own
and work for another company so even
though it's funny because where did it
all come from well it came from the
desire
to help poor people we should make sure
that everyone can get an education so
what we're going to do is
is federally subsidized student loans so
that anyone can take out a loan and then
anyone can get a college education and
look what happened
look at the housing colleges decided
exactly because and according to the
national bureau for economic research
pretty
straightforward conclusion they came to
but it's always good to actually cite
a reputable think tank they said that
colleges respond to federal subsidies
by increasing their tuition yeah it's
it's really straightforward
uh and so yeah it started as let's help
poor people let's help them get an
education education's a great thing and
it resulted in this massive dystopian
nightmare where almost everyone in our
generation is unbelievably in debt
and who is it helping it's helping the
rich i've had a lot of
i used to have a lot of people hit me up
about traveling the world and covering
news when i was doing it now i got
people hitting me up about youtube and
stuff but yeah so back in the day
you know when i was at vice and
everything people would be like i want
to do what you do man like oh i want to
travel around
and i usually complain that millennials
don't actually want to do the work
yeah like yeah i've seen your video on
this so i've talked about how like i've
had people say
well i mean i don't want to spend the
money like i have a really nice
apartment in brooklyn
and i'm like what's more important going
to you know i don't know ukraine for
this crisis and covering it and being
there
or having your nice apartment in
brooklyn but i like my apartment in
brooklyn
okay the other thing though is that a
lot of people said
i can't have student loan debt i'm like
can you quit your job right now take
your savings and fly i mean i could but
how am i gonna pay my student loans back
yep
can you defer them like but then the
interest is gonna get really bad it's
like
okay well then you congratulations you
signed your soul away
for what this is exactly how they get
you they put you in a cycle where you
start out where you owe
this massive student loan and they keep
you in your work forever just forever
you just sign a contract for the rest of
your life to just be like okay
what are you doing now they do 100
deferred mine for 20 years i'm still in
deferment i just
never want to pay those back you can't
do anything about it you can't
bankruptcy
he's just banking on the whole system
collapsing before he will face that
offense yeah let's just wait
let's wait until the last election is
over i gotta be honest
i gotta be honest his investment is
about to pay out in space
november november 4th and i'm good
that's the the entire like we all think
we're worried about the election
ian has his entire financial future
riding on it it's like if this
happened my plan was to bankrupt i
graduated 2001 and i was gonna bankrupt
my student loan debt you can't do that
but
george bush in like 2003 made it illegal
cannot bankrupt your student loans you
got to keep them
well yeah and i guess like they can't
repossess a degree so that's the
brilliance of it you could never
ever ever default on those i was in a
unique college situation where it was
worth it i think even though i've been
in debt i've never really stressed too
much about it it's always been a
deferment i owe more than i borrowed
20. 21 years ago but i had a phenomenal
experience in college i wanted to become
an actor a journalist and then i
switched to become an actor
i was acting so i was like kind of
paying to be there to learn how to act
i met a phenomenal friend a beautiful
girlfriend and it
launched my confidence and so it was a
hands-on
degree it wasn't like i went to study
some business knowledge that i could
have learned elsewhere it was actually
like acting like it was i had a job
to do one gave me an opportunity 100 i
don't doubt that good things came out of
your college experience but
great things have come out of a lot of
people's college experiences and the
system just set up in a way where you
ended up getting screwed because
right my dad my dad paid for his entire
college education this is like the
typical boomer story but my dad paid off
his entire college education working at
jewel over the years but what tuition's
way lower back then
extra no no that's my no i'm not saying
like don't worry ian
but i am saying that it was so
unbelievably cheap back then that you
could actually do that which is
completely out the window now do people
know what jewel is jewel oscar do they
not have that is this just a chicago
thing that's right that's hilarious they
might actually not know i went down to
the jewelry area
uh save
yeah what's the ralph says what they
ralph is california yeah yeah what does
new york have
there's uh new york has covered 19 and
nothing else
they've got those really really thin
aisles
you know what it's not good for social
distancing that's why that's why i got
so bad there were too thin
i did go to college what was your degree
and set up in debt yeah so no i was
so i was unbelievably privileged i mean
i did community college for two years
but yeah
i mean my parents took care of the rest
and i was not going to go to college but
my plan was just to like keep working
and enter the industry and continue to
build my business and
my parents said no we really want you to
go and i said that's an unbelievable
gift that most people don't get so i'm
going to do that and i'm forever
grateful to them
and i continued working on my business
while
for the two years that i went away to
the school i went to which was the
savannah college of art and design and
by the time i graduated
my my enterprise was making enough money
for me to just live off of
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you